the number is 6 1 7 830 4750 we take
calls about just about anything uh who's
joining me now hi david this is nathan
from san antonio again with about the
same question how are you what's going
on well i'm looking at CNN and they have
uh Donald Trump unfavorable rating at
seventy percent and I'm calling to ask
if you think that they're gonna try to
pull some shenanigans at the Republican
National Convention yet my view has not
changed drastically from last week on
this issue I think it is is uh possible
there are definitely some elements on
the Republican side that would like to
get Trump out at any and it by any means
necessary at any cost possible and the
problem of course is unless you have a
real specific way of making sure that
your interference in the Republican
convention doesn't just help Hillary
Clinton which presumably Republicans
aren't looking to elect Hillary Clinton
you have to be real careful about it uh
so I don't know maybe we'll check in
next week and see my if my position has
changed it yes maybe it'll uh comment
further on his racist bigot uh duh yeah
what I mean of course we've been talking
about that uh that for there's no
shortage of commentary on that on the
show alright thank you so much for the
call